here's Biden talking about Donald Trump
and his documents and the Mar-A-Lago
raid from a couple months ago you saw
the photograph of the top secret
documents laid out on the floor at
Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
how could this happen how could anyone
be this responsible this is insane these
are classified documents this is serious
stuff oh well happening to Biden right
now
three sources tell CBS News the
classified documents were discovered in
this building about a mile from the
White House at the offices of the Penn
Biden Center a foreign policy Research
Institute set up after President Biden
left the vice presidency according to a
source familiar with the matter the
classified documents are small in number
and were found in November in a box
among unclassified material sources
would not characterize how sensitive the
documents are
responding to requests from CBS News the
White House Council said that on
November 2nd of last year before the
midterm elections lawyers for President
Biden were cleaning out office space at
the center when they discovered the
documents marked classified in a locked
closet they stopped the work and
contacted the White House
of course right before the election they
found this sort of thing now look when
the Mar-A-Lago thing happened I knew it
was all nonsense and nothing was going
to come of it just like impeachment one
and impeachment two an impeachment for
three scoops ice cream and impeachment
for holding the glass of water with two
hands and all of that stuff I I'm not
even saying that this is such a huge
deal but you do have to acknowledge and
this is the key part I think the
difference in the way the media will
cover these leaked secret classified
documents versus Donald Trump's but I
know that's not a surprise to you right
you're not going oh my God I really
thought they were going to be equal 50
50 on this thing of course they won't be
also uh let's not pretend that Biden had
anything to do with this I mean Biden is
just so not even in charge he's not in
charge of putting his shoes on right so
the idea that he was personally doing
this stuff however the buck does have to
stop with someone and that's why people
eventually up top have to be taken out
like you're in charge of the operation
but the point is if this if a scandal is
going to take down Joe Biden I think
there's far worse scandals to take down
Joe Biden just yesterday we talked about
this story how the administration was
directly and they can link it basically
up to Biden from an email that they were
censoring Tucker Carlson on Twitter at
the behest of the Biden Administration
like that's impeachment level stuff so I
don't know that anything's going to come
of this but I think it's just worth
making a note that when it was Trump
all hell was going to break loose this
is the Smoking Gun we finally got him 87
other impeachments orange man bad and
this one of course will just basically
be ignored
[Music]
foreign
[Music]